I think it confirms the angil, not the
Bible we have today.
>> What's the angel if it's not my Bible?
>> It's the one that was revealed to Jesus
at at its time.
>> Yeah, but the Quran says that the
Christians had it in Muhammad's time.
So,
>> Oh, uh,
y'all got nothing. [laughter]
>> It's okay. [gasps]
But um I mean it would have to be my
Bible, you know, because we have those
manuscripts from Muhammad's time and
even before
uh cuz I see some of the like
of the um scriptures that wasn't not in
Muhammad's time, but the scriptures you
say that you have today.
>> Yeah. Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
>> Those are the ones who wrote the gospel
of Jesus.
Okay.
>> And so we have manuscripts of those from
you know Muhammad's time and even before
way before.
>> So what's like what's the what's your
argument for?
>> So my argument is is that because the
Quran says that my Bible is true
uh that therefore the Quran is false for
going against the Bible. Right? The
Bible says when we read when I read the
Bible it says Jesus is the son of God.
The Quran says obviously that Jesus is
not the son of Allah, right? And whoever
says that is cursed by Allah and deluted
from the truth. The Bible says that
Jesus was crucified and rose again on
the third day. The Quran says that it
was only made to appear that Jesus was
crucified but they killed him not nor
did they crucify him. Um the Quran says
that I'm sorry that the Bible says that
Jesus is our Lord, our God, right? One
in essence with the father and the holy
spirit. The Quran says that Jesus is
nothing more than a messenger, just a
human being who ate food. So, it
contradicts the Bible. And these these
just a few examples I gave it. There's
so many more, but these are just some
important ones where the Quran clearly
contradicts what the Bible says while at
the same time saying the Bible's true.
So therefore, the Quran can't be it
can't be true. It has to be false.
>> Okay.
Well, how do you know it's like not the
Bible that's false? the Quran
>> because the Quran says the Bible's true.
>> Oh. Oh, yeah. That's true.
>> If the Bible's
>> like, let's go, let's go that other way.
If the Bible was false, then the Quran
would be false for saying the Bible's
true. If it says a false book is true,
then the Quran is false for for lying.
No, that book is not. The Bible's not
true. It's actually false. And the
Quran's wrong for saying it's true. So
either way you go, if the Bible's true,
the Quran is false for contradicting it.
If the Bible's false, then the Quran is
false for saying that the Bible's true.
>> True. Yeah. I I have nothing else to
>> Yeah. This this is something serious to
think about, man. This is this is like
probably my number one reason why I say
Islam is false, man. Because of this
right here, it's it's the biggest
problem. And there's no way out of it.
There's no way out of it. It's a clear
demonstration of how Islam is false,
man.
>> All right. Yeah.
>> How long have you been a Muslim?
>> Uh, couple weeks.
>> Couple weeks.
>> Yeah. I'm not going to lie. Yeah.
>> What convinced you to be a Muslim?
>> They were talking about how it's
preserved and B's been changed. So, I'm
like, I guess that could be true. I'm
like, let me just try Oh man, you was a
easy shahada, huh?
You was a easy shahada, huh?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, they got you. But, uh,
fortunately, God brought you to this
stream. What's up, George? Love you,
man. Uh, God brought you to to this
stream to show you that you've been
duped and they lied to you and they, you
know, sold you a nice sales pitch like
how cars salesmen try to do. They try to
sell off a car with a bunch of uh
insurance on it and try to hide all the
real expensive things and how it's
broken down and stuff. That's what they
did. They they so they gave you a good
little sales pitch and you wasn't
knowledgeable enough to recognize their
lies.
But that's what God raised people up
like me for so that you don't have to
follow a lie.
So, so as quickly as you joined Islam
should be even quicker that you leave
it, bro. There's no way that you should
still be in this religion. Absolutely
not.
What are your thoughts on Jesus?
>> Man, I love Jesus, but I do, but it was
the um the Trinity that made me like
question it. That's what that's what
really got me. [clears throat]
>> So, doubting that Jesus is God.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I understand. And did they tell
you that Jesus is not God, but that he's
submitted to God and that he's just a
servant and just a messenger?
>> And
>> yeah, they also want to John 17 to 17:3.
>> Yeah, that's good. Let's go to John 17.
Let's go to John 17. Do you have a
second device on you or no?
>> All right. It's okay if you don't. It's
all right.
>> I'm going just read John 17. I'm gonna
read verses 1 to5. Okay.
>> All right. Did they show you the
context? Did they show you the verses
before or after?
>> Just the verse.
>> Just just John 17:3. Yeah.
>> Isn't that amazing?
>> Now, I'm I'm going to show you what they
hid from you.
>> Now, you tell me this. [clears throat]
If I were to ask you like, who's the one
who gives eternal life? Who would you
say that is?
>> God.
>> Exactly. Watch what Jesus says. John 17
verse one. When Jesus had spoken these
words, he lifted up his eyes to heaven
and said, "Father, the hour has come.
glorify your son that your son may
glorify you since verse two. Since you
have given him authority over all flesh
to give eternal life to all whom you
have given him. Hold on a second, Jesus.
Whoa, whoa, whoa. Jesus, you're supposed
to be a good prophet. You're supposed to
be a good messenger. What you just said
is sherk. It's it's idolatry. Jesus just
said one, he's the son of God who God
glorifies and he glorifies God. They mut
they glorify each other. Two, he said
that he has authority over all flesh and
that he's the one who gives uh gives
eternal life to whoever the father gives
him.
So how can Jesus be a mere messenger if
he's claiming to have authority over all
flesh, all creation, and also give
eternal life? Does that sound like
somebody who thinks he's just a mere
man?
>> No.
>> No. Does that sound like a good Muslim
prophet? Would a Muslim prophet ever
claim that he has authority over all
flesh who can give eternal life?
>> No. That's sherk.
>> That's sherk.
This is the verse right before
verse three. So they gave you verse
three thinking that Jesus excludes
himself when he says, "And this is
eternal life." Let's read it. And this
is eternal life that they may know you,
the only true God and and Jesus Christ
whom you have sent. So see it's over.
Jesus says the father is the only true
God. Uh uh that's not at ne he's not
negating himself. He's just glorifying
the father like we just read him doing
in verse one. He's glorifying the
father. That doesn't mean that he's
negating himself as being God as well.
But that's what the trinity is. The true
God is the father, the son, and the holy
spirit. And one person can recognize the
other person as true God just like the
father also calls the son god as well in
other verses.
>> Yeah.
>> This is what we would expect if God was
a trinity.
And so watch what else he says. He says
I now this is verse four. I glorified
you on earth having accomplished the
work you gave me to do. Now father him
pay attention to this. Now, Father,
glorify me in your presence with the
glory that I had with you before the
world existed.
Jesus just said that he had the same
glory with the father. They shared the
same glory together before creation.
Does this sound like somebody that's
just a man?
>> No.
>> No. This sounds like somebody who knows
that he himself has the same divine
essence as the father, who is just as
much God as the father is, but is also a
humble servant of the father who does
the work that his father calls him to
do. Even though he shares the same
essence, even though he shares the same
glory,
this is how Christ speaks. What the
Muslims did is they isolated verse
three, gave you a false narrative and
you wasn't, you know, you didn't have
that awareness to say, "Hold on, let me
actually look and see what Jesus is
saying in context." Because the context
kills them. In context, Jesus is
claiming to be God while also glorifying
the father as God as well.
>> Yeah. They also said that um he
prostrated to the father and that's what
made him.
>> That's what makes [laughter]
Yeah.
>> So if I prostrate to a statue, am I a
Muslim? [laughter]
>> No. But
no, cuz they said like
>> You see how silly that is? There there's
Have you uh Have you heard of Orthodox
Christianity?
>> Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Cuz they do
prostrate.
>> They prostrate. Are they Muslims?
>> No.
>> No. [laughter]
That's so stupid. Uh here's another
thing. When Jesus prostrates, he calls
God his father, right? He says, "Father,
if it be possible in Islam, is is Allah
the father?"
>> No.
>> No, he's not. So, in the very verse that
they go to to try to prove that Jesus is
a Muslim, it actually proves he's far
from it. Because in that same prayer,
he's acknowledging that God is his
father and he's God's son.
He can't be Muslim. He's everything he's
everything of the opposite.
Make sense?
Yeah.
>> So, you joined a religion you didn't
even you didn't even know about, man.
You didn't know they was lying to you
like this, man.
>> They were they were just like they were
just telling me how uh Jesus uh didn't
know the hour and how he prospered. I'm
like, "Yeah, that does make sense." So,
>> so do you see now how with all of these
things that we're going through and we
could do this all the time. There's
nothing in there in their claims that
actually holds weight. When we go into
their little script and how they go
against Jesus, we see that they're liars
and we see that Jesus actually does
claim to be God. He claims divine things
that no Muslim prophet can claim, no
creature can claim, no angel can claim.
Right? We see these things about Jesus
in the Bible and what he says while at
the same time we also see his humility.
We also see him in in the role of a
servant.
So those two things are not mutually
exclusive. Jesus can be divine. He can
be God and also have the virtues of
humility and servitude as well
to give us an example.
>> Yeah.
>> Make sense?
So, um, have you read the Bible yet or
no?
>> I only read like John, like a little bit
of John.
>> A little bit of John.
>> Yeah.
>> Start it over. Start it over. Read
through John, bro. And uh, and see what
Jesus really said about himself. Jesus
says some crazy things about himself
that you would be like, "Yeah, there's
no way." Uh, I can't believe people say
he never claimed to be God. He clearly
claimed to be God in John. And well, we
remember we just read a few verses in
John 17. Wait till you read John 1, John
chapter 5. John chapter 5 is insane.
John chapter 5, John 6.
Okay. Read read the gospel. But um
>> but yeah, what what are your thoughts on
Islam now? You still a Muslim?
>> Not really. I was just confused about
the about the like the the verses and
stuff.
>> Yeah. Praise God. Well, brother, look,
I'm here if you need me, man. Follow me.
Give me a follow. I'm live every Monday,
Wednesday, or Friday, same time.
>> You can come up anytime and ask
questions. You can message me, ask
questions, remind me. Hey, man. This is
King Boy. We we spoke uh you know, I was
the new Muslim or whatever. Um and I can
and because the job's not done. You left
Islam. You're done with Islam. You see
the falsehood of Islam, which is good,
but now you have to see the truth of
Christ and you have to see the gospel.
So, there's so much I I there's so much
I got to show you, bro. It's going to
blow your mind.
All right. So, stay in touch. Okay.
>> All right. Bye.
>> All right. Peace, man. Take care of
yourself. All right.
>> You, too.
>> All right. Peace.
>> Yep. Come back, King Boy. Come back. Do
not uh don't let it go too far where we
don't talk again. Let's Let's talk
again, man. Let's talk again.
Let's talk again.